[Music]
time for pft on yahoo sports peter king
mike florea with some of the big stories
in the national football league big
weekend for the nfl the divisional round
is upon us and peter a point i made
earlier today on pft live as we
constantly look for the next peyton
manning and tom brady quarterback
rivalry one of the reasons we're having
a hard time finding it is there's so
many great quarterbacks now we don't
need one rivalry to be the centerpiece
and so this weekend we're going to see
some great quarterback match-ups we're
going to see josh allen and lamar
jackson as the bills host the ravens
we're going to see some other great ones
too which is the one that stands out to
you the most
the easiest one to say is brees and
brady because it it could be the last
game of breeze's career
and it also could be the last game of
tom brady's
20th season as a starter in the nfl and
you know and who knows what the future
holds but by far i i'm really excited
about lamar jackson against josh allen
because both of these guys are babies in
the game
and there's a chance perhaps a good
chance that both will win in multiple
mvps before they retire josh allen's
going to win one mike he's probably not
going to win it this year but he is
going to win one and the contrast in
styles
i made this point in my column this week
okay even if lamar jackson doesn't last
and play till he's 43
i want lamar jackson to be
the lamar jackson that we saw on sunday
take off run
57 yards 77 yards 17 yards it doesn't
matter
that is his
game
and if he only lasts 13 years instead of
20 that's okay
he needs to play
the lamar jackson white he's got a great
arm
he doesn't have a great wide receiving
core but he's got a great arm and he's
got even better legs and i love this
josh allen can do both
you know as i keep saying the only shame
of this is there's only going to be 6
700 people and not 67 000
in the stands to really make it one of
the great atmospheres in recent nfl
history
and the thing about lamar jackson you
say it's not sustainable into his 40s
you know people thought it wasn't
sustainable into his mid-20s that's
what's amazing that there's never been a
question about his durability he had the
issue where he had to go into the locker
room because he had cramps or cramps as
the case may be whatever it was he's
always available he doesn't get injured
he's always there even as he throws his
body into harm's way so i have a feeling
he's going to be around for a while and
an exciting player in a great matchup
and maybe josh allen and lamar jackson
will become kind of like a tom brady
payton manning thing
another reason why they're connected
they were both first round picks in 2018
and we believed after the 2019 season
that lamar jackson the last pick in
round one was far and away the best now
we have the guy who was the first pick
in baker mayfield who is emerging
again after a bad second season and he
gets together with patrick mahomes peter
these two guys in college in 2016 had a
game with a final score of 66 to 59
so i don't think it's going to be
anywhere close to that but i'm very
excited to see baker mayfield and
patrick mahomes in a game where the
winner advances and the loser goes home
baker mayfield has this chip on his
shoulder that he doesn't mind showing us
time and time and time again he doesn't
want to be the cool guy who fits in uh
to everybody's version of what he should
be he's just going to be himself i
talked to jarvis landry sunday night
after their win over the steelers and he
said this guy just continues to overcome
everything the outside world throws at
him and i agree i give the browns a
chance in this game mike
look at this
the kansas city chiefs have not won a
game
by more than a touchdown
since november 1st
i mean this is not a steamrolling chiefs
team
the browns will keep this one close
and and all they need at this point is
either tyreek hill or travis kelsey to
come out and say the browns is the
browns
then we'll know
that the browns are ready to take down
the chase all right that's it for pft on
yahoo sports peter king i'm mike florio
we'll see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports